COTRYOR A CNGE.
LET' BNGN FRIDA GOVERR
RON DESTIS.
HENO ABOUT THE
ALLEES O GTING
ERAPTICS F HIS STA WEL
TESTING.
EVEN YR CRICS WOULDAY Y
E A M OCTIOWE A I A NIONWE SHOAE
EN IT CES T TTS.
DO Y HAV SOMETHI TO SAYO
>> YH, BRI, YOU KW, THE
DENDMINISTRION PMISED
THEREOING TO SENLLTHE AHOME TESD
AN GET IT. D WO OINE
NOTHG HA HAPPENEN A MONTH
D A HAL OF DOI THATE LOO
ATNLODAND S Y KNOTH POINT OTHE T
ER SINE PSON NEE TO B
GOIN OUT AAYSETNGESTED.
YOHA HEAHYEOPLE.
TH'S NOT AOOD SATEGWH IS AOOD SO
VEHESET HOME TTSAVAIBLEORUR VNE.
HAVE SECED 1 MILON AHOESTSWEREN
NG-TM CARE FACITIE
AN THE TO THE BADERENIODA
POPUTION.THROUGHT O
BECAE,E VIE TTINGS
METHGHAT OULD LEAD TO
TH A CLICA REST.
E HE EMBCED ELYTRTMEN IN FLODA
SO IFOU HAV SEBOD THAS
ELDEY THA MAY BULRABL
COV THE C GET AUICK
TE AT MEON'T HAV TOAIT
ININE.
IFHE ARE UPO THE HAVEHE
TH TSE.S BUT THE FERGORNMESEINGE
SOHAT FLORIDISET WT THEY
NE.
SOIT IS AZINGHATOU A
THE WLENCHILADA TY SULSE U WOD O
BE AE TOOHING WHEASOU
VE TEN,BVIOLY MTERS
INTO YRWN HDS T TRY TO
T, YOU KW, IIKEHAT YOU
HAVE JUSAID,EGARNG TFA THAT YOUT
EVERODYEEDS TO  TESD BUT
E VNERABLEO.
BECAUS ULTATEL WT W ARE
EINGITHHE OMIONS,OU
OW,Y WHO FAMILAD I
OUNDHRISTMASIME.
ANDTASN' UNTIL ONEF U
T  I GOT THEIR TES
ERET'S LE OKA YOU ND
TO KPWAYROMOUR FAMY,
>> ILREA INFECD EVEBODY.
T YOU HE G TOTAY AY
OM GNDMATH'S WT Y AALKING
BEUSEEOPL DO NEED T BE
CCINED, BST,ND TESD
TO KP ERYBODY SE.>>ELL, THAS TH.
THI YOU HE SITTION
WHER OMICR, TNKFULLY MH
LESS PHOUG GEN THA DTA.
A L OFHEOSPIL AISSISIN FRIDA ANE
ADMIED FOR SETHI ELS A
HAPP TOESTOSITIVE.
EY ARE N ENOH FROMOVID
TO BE TRTEDN AOSTAL.
THAT ISN MAN WAY A GD
VELOENTOR HOW THIHING
PEOPLEND ELDLY PPLE.NERABLE
D TSE ARE TOLKS THA WE
NT TO ME SUR WERE ABL TO
FOE PPLEOEST TO BBLSDFO OR FE TR
GO TO SOOLR TO BE ABL TO
TH ISOT A GD USE O
AND THAS PT OHE REASO
BECAUSEOU HE A LOT OOW
LUE TESNG GNG ON.
>>insley: VERN, TRE IS
ANRTLE IN VANIT FAISAYS
IN OOBERHERE W PROSAL.
EYPPACHE BIDENBOUTOU
ED T BUYOT OF TSE
TES.
U NDOUY 732 MLION
STSECSE W NEE TO BE
EPAR FOR THE HIDAY SUR.SOANY IN.
TOOECAU PPLE DIDT WT
G O OF THE CNTRYECSE
U COUN'TACK I I Y WE
'ANDOU CLD BE PITIV FOR
MONT.
THIS P A L OF PREUREN
YOUND YOU STATE.
WE CE DOWNHERE ANDLL
LOINGOR TES.
THE MDLE OFHE VACIO
THE TESTS WEONET Cs
WEOULD G A PHONE CALL A
RUSH ORHERE TYUST RUN
OU
WH CAN W EECT THO TOE
R
NURSINGOMES LG-TE CAREIKY GO
CITIESND LIKYO T
LOCALOMMUTIESHERE THE CAN
FOS THN ELDLY PEOE.
IGREE I TNK WE ND TO HE
E SHEES RTOCK
MMERALLY
WEAD H REALL N PBL
WIHEHAT FORONTHS AND
BUTECSEMICRONS S
WISPRE YOU SEE THA I THI
TH THE ACTLLYEEN SE
CAH UON THAINSLEY.
THINK TREAS AN ITIAL
PAC WHEMICRON HND MEDHYERIA
PELE A STARTINO
DERSND TS IS SETHITH'S OHERE
FO MT PEOPLETS MORE AN
TH'S AREAT TNG.
YO D'T NESSALYEED TO BE
FOR NOEASO DOI THEESTS
CLINICAL TOE AE TO
NERA AN OCOME.
IHINKHATE D WILLE
LPFUL.
IO TNK YRE GOI TO
STAR TOEE ME A MOR OF
Bri:  COUE O THIS,
GOVEOR.
YOUENTIED TRAPEICS.
ANBODIES.THE MONOCLOL
ALSO TFIZE
ORDED ANHE10 MLION
PFIZ.
HE 20 MILLN PZERILLS.
YOU NEEDIVE PLS IN0 DS
WATCHINGHISIGHTOW TTEVEWODN'TAVE
OMRON, YOU GETIGHT THRGH
IT QUILY,OU NOOU SEEHE
LL BACK ON TRAPEICSHE
PRESENTASISMISSIV YOU ANOGOIN TT
AVTHEILLS
WHY DOOU TNK THE FEDAL
VERNNT DOESOT WT US T
>> WL, I THI I YOU LOO
CK, ER IS NUMR OF B
FAILES IN TS PANMIC,HE
SCHO CLORES WCH KNO Y
YS WERALKI ABO, SOME
EOCKDN POLIES, OF
BUTHEAIRE FM THE OSET
TO REALLY FOCUS ON THEPEUTS,
I TNK,AS CT HE NUMR
LOCKWN MASKSND THE OE
WAS IT A WEAVE SEE NOWPAICAR B N
OPLE ARE STI GETNG
AFFEED REGARESSF
VAINATIONTATUYO NEE TO HAVE EHAS
I TNKT'S COUNTER THEIR
MESSINGND NRATI.
ANTIDYITESHIS SUMMERHEY
TACK ME,OUREGAINST
VAINEF YO ARE FOR
HA AOT O VACNATEEOPL W
INGT WN'T A
VACCAT.
REGARDSS Y WAN TO HEEATMT OPTIO.
IN FRIDA WEAVE RLLYSTREEDHAT.
GOODOB TKING AUTT IT'E A
EN A HUGE, HE PBLEMROM
TH PANMIC RESNSE AND
PARTICARLYNDER T BIDEN
ADMISTRAON WREOT OY
E TH NOT PROMOTI
THEREUTI TY A AUALLTRNG TTYMI TE
MOCLON A ATHIS INT
DIES
PEOP ARE DYI BECSE O
IS.
>> NOUESTION.RINAL.
ONG PEOPLEIDN'T EVE KW
WHENEOLLE O THE SITES.
WE STAEDETNG MESSAS T
MYFFE FMTHER STE
PELE SING HEY DIDT EN
STATE?WUT TRE.CANOUELPE GET I IM
THERE WA HELVAILLE.TEM
VEMENTBVIOLY, GOVNOR,L
KNEWHERE W GOING TE
TRBL RIG ABO N BECSE
SAID THAWE'RNTERG T
WIER OEATH
DT' GOI TO BE A WINTER O
THEAYEFOR J BEN SAIDEAY O
Y, W KNOWT'S B, BUT GE
US ME TE.
SO W CANET THEESTS O.
OUT DHIS LIK THAT.ZERIL
BU Y KW,HAT'HYE WAS
ECTE
HEND RON KIN MAD TITCH
WHENHEY WEREUNNG,HEN HWAS NNINGT
HEAI Y KW, HIRE ME
AND N TNK THAS THET SFFDONE
FRUSATIO
NO ONL DN I FLODA BUT ALL
ROHE COUNTRY BAU THE
FEDEL GORNMENT AO A
THERE A AOT OF PEOPLHO
DOWNHE VUSO WANREATNTD N'TETT. T
EVER D.MAGOGD DALDRUMP
AND DEATHMP FOR CID CES
HE DIDTLAME CHI, WHICH I
REAL WHERE TLAMEELON.
BU HE SAI IT WLL TRUMPFAT A HE I
WN.
YOUAVEASES AND SPPINGS IN
HA NEV SEEEFORYIKE WE
SOHAT FDAMEAL PMI HE
MADEO TMERIN PPLE HEHA AOLUTELYO
D HONTLY,TAS DEMOGUERY
FR T BEGNING
U C'T JUS MAGALLYHU
DOWN A RESRATOIRUS
HE WOULD DOOEL MITATENDPRIDEHES.
AT WASN'WHATE W DOING
AT CTRAL PROSE HASAILE
HE SHOD N HAV BEE
NO WHE HEEES THEESUL HE
SAYG WLT'S NOT REALL
THEEDEROVERENSREONSILITY
IT ALL ABO WHA THE STATES
OULDEOING
I CELL YOU, STE,HAT'
T WH HE WAS SING T
FLIDA AND XASHISUMR.
HE W BMING US FOR N
IMPOS MAAT AND
RESTCTIO EVE TUGH WE HE
DO MUC BETR IN TMS OFUR
CIET AND ENOMY AND
EDUCATN.
SO, TT I JUS WT TY ARE
AND IHINK TY HE GOT
THEYADE ALL THERANDSE
PROMES.
THEYSEDT T TRYO WINHE
ELTION.
AN NOW THE BILLS ARE COMGUE
AND TH ARE JT NOTBLE TO
CASH THE DEB
Ainey: REPRENTAVE EC
ALWELL O INALIFNIA HE
SUST FEWAYS AGO BLAMI
G
COVID.
ISS WT HE TETEDUT ASWE E 202 MIA
ESE GUY REPLICA LIA.
YOURACATN CCELE YR
DS BKO VIRTU LEAING
AN BAC T MASKS EVEWHER FOR
#THE GS.NO FARTH TN
HE IS CGHTITHO AASK.
HES STINGOWN IN A
CHAI
NO AT A DINRABLE
TALKG THESE DOW TRE
NEW YR'S.CISTM BRE AND
SHEAS SEENITHO A MASKND
YO MAS OFF AT A DNER TAB.SOHATS.
BUUGNGEOPL AT THISAR
ATHIS CLU
AN DANCINGROUND.
NO MAS
AN THEN I HEAOU I THINKYO WERN M
SOMEFHESE DOCRAC STAS
VACATIONG.FLORIDANN
AT D YOUAKE O TS?
LES F TE AND NOTOR M
LOCKWN PITIANSHATAVECK DOW THE ,
CTUR THE PEOPLE, C
TTAGE IUSTRYOHAVE GERNORS,OU HE
CONGRESS THEAY ONE TNGND
THENHEY LIV UNDERIFFENT
SE OULES.
ISEAVE SDOU HE TT FRIDA
ABILY TOAKEOURWNDESIONYO KW, WEO
TO TEMRATU KALE YRNMT
EEMS A RN YOUR
VELIODS.
OSEOLICIESEREOLIC
AGAITNDET, THE WILOMED
FREEM.AUNSHE A FLORIDA
I'M GLAHAT FLODA I
REGE FOR PEOE.
WE ARE HAP WH WHA WE E
IS I RULG CSS MENTALI
ERE EY TNKHAT TY CAN
IMPO TSE ON OTH PEOEUT
Ban: YINGO RUN ATATEANT ESPSE.
AND N AAMIL
D YR WIFE CEY IS GNGTHUGH NCERRT
NOW H TGH THIS HE
BE.
JU KNOWERE PULNG FOROU
AND WNOW SPEAL WH AOUNG
SO BT OFUCKITH TTS.
EATMT.
>>HEUTPOIN FOR MYIFE
HABEENANSTICAOT OF YOU VIERS, AS
KNO SND I VER MH
ITAKES DFERENCE.
AND TH PYERSAKE BIG
DIFFEREN.
SO, TNKS, EVERYBO,HO HAS
HADER BACK.
Bri: THK YOU.VERN, TNKFO